[Music]
and already so patiently if you could
take off don't wait
tomorrow oh listen to this venom returns
bingo okay brock tell the world
it's gonna be carnage
you bet your ass
even when i got kicked to the curb
let there be carnage including the song
last one standing by skyler gray
featuring polo g mozzie and eminem
directed by andy serkis rated pg-13
exclusively in movie theaters tomorrow
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
you live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it
again
you are a loser
eddie brock i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
jesus why me
what's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not a crazy man
[Music]
[Music]
i will let you eat everybody
i promise oh yeah
eddie
you'd feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
[Music]
you